what does it mean to be a queen
I work hard in every aspect of my life
in my career on my body in my spirit and
I deserve somebody who mirrors that
that's a queen then I need a prince
so I need a king
I'm someone who has the addictive
personality trait I can attach myself to
anything and overdo it it's destructive
I've been a bit Reckless I'm learning to
unlearn things that's taking a lot of
work on my end because I didn't realize
I was the chaos
in the past I used to do things to seek
approval what would they think about
this or that I'm not there anymore I'm
afraid of people well new people like to
hurt you it's really hard for me to let
my guard down but it's time to kind of
take the bricks down
as individual women all of us have
experienced a lot of the same trauma
verbal abuse domestic violence very
public relationships it's a lot I'm like
am I cursed am I hex why do they always
end up like this
wasn't twinkling mine was today it was
river dancing
you can't come over here trying to be
funny when I'm just chilling you smell
me oh red flag there's this problem me
Santa is close to you no you should back
up
you're gonna have to pray for us
right hook left hook so that door is
open oh that door is wide open
[Applause]
like a little p-i-m-p around here
it's not gonna take nothing for this man
to get my vagina you like nipple clamps
sis I'm open to it
because we've been through like so much
when someone is so nice to you thank you
I have to tell myself it's okay to be
treated this way
it is not going to be easy to become a
king to one of our Queens the question
is are you the man they're looking for
this journey do it by yourself I just
don't know if he's genuine I don't want
to have a conversation about it because
who you got your eyes on may not have
their eyes on you I think you've had
plenty of time I would like for you to
go pack your bags and leave the house
tonight all that said and done
you are not our King
we need someone who knows how to treat a
queen
I want it to be the real thing all these
years I haven't been chasing love I feel
like it came will you marry me